hi there Steve Kaufman here again to
talk about language learning and if you
enjoy my videos please subscribe today I
want to talk about the what I call the
stages of language learning with
particular reference to what I'm doing
right now I have in the past said that
there are two stages and I'm compared it
to an upside-down hockey stick where in
the first period which might be two or
three months or longer depending on how
different the language is it's a very
steep climb it's very tough but we're
motivated by the fact that we're
discovering something new that we have
no understanding of before then you get
to this long sort of the flat part of
this inverted hockey stick where just
seems to go on forever because there's
so many words to learn but it's not as
tough going but I thought about it and
just before I made it video I thought
there is perhaps a third stage which is
where you start to go downhill downhill
in the sense that things become easier
and if I look at my own languages in
Hebrew I'm very much at the beginning of
the steep climb in Greek I'm nearing the
top of the steep climb for many of my
languages I'm on the flat part of the
hockey stick where I can at any time
pick up you know listen I can read but I
have obvious problems when I speak but
they're there in potential those
languages are put in enough effort that
I can at any time go in there and
enjoyably continue listening and reading
without too much struggle and just
continue to improve and with more
speaking I would improve more then I
have those languages that I speak very
well where I enjoy using them I don't
worry too much about mistakes that I
make but I know that the more I use them
the more I read and listen the more I
speak the better I will continue to get
and in a way these three stages
correspond to what the European Common
framework of reference refers to a a 1
and 2 which kind of a beginner level B
which is this intermediate level which I
consider to be the longest period like
to get from b1 to b2 is a huge
step and then see is when you are
getting close to being comfortable
fluent whatever the term is you can use
it in any situation you don't make a lot
of mistakes and yeah I don't that just
go on it goes on forever but you're not
worried at least at least in my case I'm
not worried about improving so much in
those languages they're just there
so getting back to Hebrew now I've been
at Hebrew for a week and I'm at the
stage now where I can actually hear the
sounds of the language when I when I
listen I can hear where one word begins
and the next word sorry one word ends on
the next word begins I have listened as
I'm basically working with our many
stories of link I have listened to the
first story I don't know 20 times more
I've read it many times gone through it
you know clicked on the word to get the
text-to-speech all of these stories are
put in my playlist so that if I'm
driving I can hear them it is a la it's
a big struggle I am constantly amazed at
the ability of the brain to forget you
know I'm struggling to read these Hebrew
letters and I keep on getting them wrong
even after I kind of read the word and
read and this is you know pronounced
like a T and this is pronounced like a a
B and a V forget the fact that some
letters mysteriously can be pronounced
as a beer of E or as a V you know who
but you know the brain just forgets it
forgets words it forgets letters but I
also know from experience that this
whole forgetting process is part of the
learning process so eventually these
these things will stick as it has with
Greek because when I started Greek I had
the same difficulty not as tough because
Greek actually is is written the way
it's pronounced so it's it's a much
easier pattern for the brain to pick up
on Hebrew is more difficult but I know
from experience I will eventually get
there so I'm fighting my way and because
I'm so
and I'm enjoying discovering the
languages the language you start to
discover patterns and I'm helped a lot
by I mentioned enough Twitter feed this
reversal verb conjugator and in the verb
conjugator it shows you it highlights
which you know part which form of the
verb this is now the first 20 stories at
link are all in the present tense so
typically slots in and it turns out that
in Hebrew there's only one for well
there's only a masculine and feminine
feminine and a plural form for the
present tense
there's no doesn't change for person I
you he and stuff which is interesting I
kind of took a peek of the other tenses
looks a bit more complicated but the
reversal conjugator also gives you the
little dots there the nakute which helps
in terms of the pronounciation so I like
referring to that it's another form of
exposure I review all the different
forms of the verb I read the new code
with the help of the new code and it
also has the the phonetic you know
transliteration into you know Latin or
Roman script underneath so that's kind
of part of what I'm doing and I just go
through these stories and you know I'm
just amazed at how little I understand
after having gone through it so many
times and listened so many times but I
do have the feeling that I'm starting to
get better
I can read better and that was my
initial goal to get to where I can read
because if I can read better than I'm
gonna be able to eventually understand
better when I listen so this is the
stage it's that first period I think if
I weren't going to Israel in October I
would think that Hebrew is a year's
project normally I have an hour a day
and I'm still doing a bit of Greek so
you know that's what it is but I'm kind
of pushing it a little harder now
especially cuz my wife's away for three
days so I have more time to spend on
Hebrew although I'm going to play it off
now with my son so this is there you're
tough slogging right but then once you
reach a stage where you essentially can
read and understand a lot of things but
there's a lot of words that you don't
know I mean this is this long road there
are
I mean the vocabulary that you need to
have at least for what I want to do in a
language to where I can understand
normal conversation people talking about
a variety of subjects movies and stuff
like that you actually need a lot of
words
however it's enjoyable it's a bit like
if you went cross-country skiing if
you're if the first part of the the
trail is a steep climb but you know you
have to give up that steep climb you're
slipping and you're fighting your way up
that steep climb but once you get climb
but once you get to the plateau it's a
it's a flatter still might be slightly
uphill the occasional occasional
downhill uphill the that's more
pleasurable and you're watching the the
watching the scenery go by you and stuff
it takes a lot of time to start to
notice things I'm already starting to
notice certain patterns starting to
notice the hawk which means the you know
is and when it but it slammed into the
next word and so there's stuff that you
start to notice slowly now people have
sent me references references to grammar
I've looked up references and stuff and
that also helps it also else but
eventually a lot of the stuff you have
to start noticing your self so again the
first period is the steep climb the
content that I'm listening to cannot be
so interesting because it has to be
stuffed with a lot of repetition it has
to be simple but we're motivated and
need at least initially to climb up to
the plateau so that then when you're at
a level where you can start to read and
listen and you're just looking for the
missing words it's gonna be more
enjoyable the kinds of content that you
can listen to and read it becomes more
interesting so right now there's there's
motivation to get there thereafter the
motivation will be more the compelling
content the interesting material that
you can listen to and it's all a
continuous process of noticing more and
more things in the language as I said in
the tweet it starts as it's a blank
jigsaw puzzle and the more pieces of the
puzzle are put in there the more other
things you start to notice and you just
keep on going and you just keep
forgetting and you're always forgetting
he right now forgetting letters in
another few
forgetting words but the whole process
of forgetting is the process of learning
and so and that but yeah so that's
basically it those are what I see as the
stage of the steep climb a long plateau
and then you finally reach a point where
it's kind of downhill not downhill in
terms of decline but downhill in terms
of it's easy and you're really enjoying
skiing down the hill without having to
work too hard okay thanks for listening
bye for now
[Music]